what's going on guys this is rob and
those of you guys who follow me on
Twitter know that I mean a post saying
there was going to be a big update today
pretty massive update in terms of the
future of this channel and and stuff
that we were going to talk about which
by the way I'm actually I just woke up a
little bit ago I'm getting ready get
into the shower here and in a little bit
and get ready for work I got some
errands I need to run beforehand but um
I was talking to Ted Benny yesterday and
I was like hey man like let me pick your
brain about DC Comics a lot of you guys
have been asking that I do what I do
with Marvel except with DC like you guys
want me to explain Batman like that Matt
explains Superman explain the Green
Lantern explained honestly I don't
really even know where to begin with DC
comics so Benny is going to be like my
life string I guess for DC I'm not
really sure like he'll help me get a lot
of this stuff sorted out which is which
is cool you know that's that's fine but
I like the idea of explaining DC
characters and a lot of the guys like I
said I've really wanted to see a lot of
guys I really wanted to know what's up
so the next thing is a story that a lot
of you guys have been asking for a lot
of you guys have wanted me to do Age of
Apocalypse for a while like a lot of you
guys been saying over and over and over
again Rob do Age of Apocalypse Rob
explain adriel pakka lips come on like I
really want to see Age of Apocalypse
here's the problem the age of apocalypse
is massive and scale if you guys thought
Civil War was big if you thought simul
war was huge some more didn't have
anything on the age of apocalypse and
the reason why is because Civil War was
more of a political thing and for the
most part it was relegated to like a
group of superheroes basically you had
like we could have gone the entire Civil
War event and not talked about like
heroes for hire we could have not talked
about the Thunderbolts like we could
have just said these are the
Thunderbolts are doing this and that's
it like we wouldn't have had to like
explain the idea of the Thunderbolts and
all that kind of stuff you know um but
with age of apocalypse it's not that way
Age of Apocalypse is not like age of
Ultron or Days of Future past with age
of Ultron he
killed pretty much everybody before the
story even started like you learned
about that and the Fantastic Four tie in
the age of Ultron where the Fantastic
Four come back from space with black
panther tells them that Ultron is
launching an attack on the planet Earth
and trying to take over and Susan storm
is like the last member of the Fantastic
Four left alive and one of the old truck
were last is advancing on her she's like
where's magneto where's all these guys
you know why are they fighting and and
Ultron's like they all fell which is
really good it's a really really cool
scene but but there that that's the
reason why they're they're all gone
because I'll try all the Ultron robots
to like kill them all off before they
could even really do anything cuz of
course Ultron was in the future he knew
where they were going to be he knew the
best time to attack so on and so forth
so Days of Future past all the
superheroes were for the most part
killed off I mean they were all gone
they were dead yeah we picked up after
everybody had died and we just kind of
learned along the way that they were all
killed off by the signals but Days of
Future past was like Marvel's first big
for a and to like a really dystopian bad
terrible future you know that was like
the second time they had ever done that
of course the first time was like the
crooked world so um you know for like
mainstream Marvel fans it was our first
time ever seeing something like that the
age of apocalypse is not that way the
age of apocalypse like everybody's alive
for the most part most everybody is
alive like Wolverine is alive Cyclops is
a lot how that goes a lot all those guys
are a lot the difference is that they're
all playing different roles like you
have the EMF and I can't over exactly
what it stands for um I can remember but
they they work for sinister but they're
under under up Hot Lips like everybody's
under apocalypse and I'm being followed
by somebody on Twitter awesome my Mac
updates twitter twitter fees
automatically it's pretty cool but um
anyway they all work under apocalypse
and the EMF is like like a groove that
goes and like does the bidding of
apocalypse they track down mutants stuff
like that but they're paired off based
on genetics so like have against Cyclops
or a team you have like the bedlam
brothers you have like all kinds of
stuff going on with those groups gambit
leads a group called the externals
Excalibur's led by Nightcrawler the
x-men is not even really like the x-men
anymore it's just like the x-men are
like all these groups that are tied in
under magneto so that's basically the
story of like magneto vs. apocalypse and
and it's so well done it is such a good
story but the issue is this all right we
can't just jump into Age of Apocalypse
it's the story that we just can't do um
Benny sent me a tweet the scissor
something a message that says movie Chop
Shop I don't know what that means I
don't have to ask me buddies talking
about oh oh no yeah that's right um okay
that'll be later well we'll get into
that much later on whoa that'll be
something yeah don't worry about that
ignore that I said that um but uh yeah
so I forgot where I was for a second
anyway there's all there's there's this
whole mishmash of things going on you
have the human High Council you have
this impending nuclear holocaust you
have juggernaut who's a monk you have
all these things taking place and so
because the story's so big and because
the story is so complicated we're going
to have to like explain the entire 1990s
x-men xfactor Excalibur x-force like all
that stuff like all the characters
basically who are involved in age of
apocalypse like all the main characters
we're gonna have to do videos explaining
them so we're going to have to explain
gambit we're going to have to explain
row we have to explain like Psylocke
storm mystique so we're gonna have to
explain the Shadow King because the
Shadow King is really important we're
going to we're definitely have to do
destiny we're gonna have to do a video
on Bishop we're gonna have to do all
these characters so this is probably
going to be the single biggest
undertaking ever on this YouTube channel
when I say ever I mean ever we're
probably never going to have an
undertaking as big as this one because
again we can't just jump into X Men let
her into Age of Apocalypse we have to
explain a gambit we have to explain the
Morlock massacre and what's going on
with game but we have to explain wove
rain we have to explain all these
different things all these different
characters and it's going to be
absolutely crazy it's going to be
absolutely nuts oh it's going to be a
while before we actually get to the age
of apocalypse the Legion quest story
proper but when we do when that time
comes
you guys are going to love it because
there's so much that happens there's so
much cool stuff it is it's one of the
best stories one of the greatest stories
ever told so anyway um with that being
said I'm gonna go and bring this video
to an end to wreak have everything of
course I'm moving in the direction of
want to do DC explained videos Age of
Apocalypse it's going to be kind of a
big deal so anyway um yeah I'll catch
you guys later peace